nous sommes en 1911 Freud le fondateur
de la psychanalyse et Young sont plus
célèbres disciples des jeunes temps
ensemble à Munich Freud lui reproche
d'avoir publié des articles dans des
journaux suisses sans mentionner son nom
young rétorque que c'est inutile parce
que son nom est déjà très connu mais
Freud insiste qu'on l'oublie dans
l'article lui déplaît vraiment ça le
blesse et puis soudain il s'évanouit ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il fait ça
devant young comment Fred
l'expliquent-ils c'est parce que je sens
qu'inconsciemment tu veux me tuer dit-il
à Young
[Musique]
certains disques Freud et le Newton de
l'esprit leur idée c'est que Freud a
révolutionné notre manière de comprendre
le monde psychique comme Newton avait
le monde physique c'est peut-être
excessif dans la mesure où Newton est un
véritable scientifique mais il est
certain que Freud a eu une énorme
influence dans la culture occidentale
ces idées ont pénétré la sagesse
populaire dont l'homme ordinaire se sert
dans sa vie quotidienne on peut
carrément dire qu'ils ont révolutionné
les mentalités elles sont notamment une
des forces à l'origine de la révolution
des mœurs des années 1960 la sociologue
américaine Cherry torkel dit dans la
France fodienne que la psychanalyse
c'est massifié parce qu'elle légitime
les conversations sur le sexe et parce
qu'elles justifie rationnellement la
libération sexuelle bref les idées de
Freud ont changé le monde mais comme la
réputation de la psychanalyse dépend en
bonne partie de la réputation sur
fondateur c'est souvent la légende de
Freud qu'on nous sert on oublie des
diamant ou inconsciemment les aspects
peu reluisants de son parcours ce qui
nous amènerait à douter de la
psychanalyse moi je vais vous raconter
10 anecdotes sur la vie de Freud des
anecdotes étonnantes et surtout
révélatrice concernant la psychanalyse
et son fondateur je pense que vous allez
être scandalisé par les dernières
anecdotes dites-moi si c'est le cas dans
les commentaires
vous avez déjà entendu parler du
complexe de DIP c'est l'idée que le
petit garçon désire inconsciemment sa
mère et que pour réaliser ce désir il a
envie de tuer son père dans le mythe
grec qui donne son nom au complexe
œdipe tue carrément son père et épouse
sa mère cette situation qui se réalise
dans la légende serait présente à l'état
de désir dans tout âme de petit garçon
mais d'où Freud tire-t-il cette
prétendue vérité psychologique
universelle et bien de son propre cas
semble-t-il il est né d'un père de 41
ans et d'une mère de 21 ans différence
d'âge et qui est lié au fait que c'était
le troisième mariage du père et la
différence explique en partie l'attitude
de l'enfant Freud il est très proche de
sa mère qui est une belle jeune femme
tandis qu'il fuit son vieux père dont la
présence ne lui est pas agréable au
début de la quarantaine il se souvient
même d'une scène précise lorsqu'il avait
trois quatre ans il a vu sa mère nue au
cours d'un voyage de nuit en train le
fondateur de la psychanalyse estime que
c'est la naissance de son désir pour sa
mère ce que montre cette anecdote c'est
qu'il est fort possible que Freud et
tout simplement généralisé son cas
personnel d'ailleurs ce soupçon n'est
pas nouveau c'est une attaque récurrente
contre la psychanalyse au tout début du
20e siècle ces lois entre guillemets
généraliserait les traumatismes
personnels de son fondateur Freud
prêtant lire les pensées des autres mais
il ne ferait que lire ses propres
pensées
si l'enfant Sigmund Freud aime sa mère
elle le lui rend bien l'amour de cette
femme belle et énergie qui lui donne
précocement la motivation et la
confiance en soi pour aller chercher la
gloire mais c'est plus généralement sa
famille entière qui croit en Freud il
est l'enfant préféré promis un destin
exceptionnel lorsque son intérêt entre
en conflit avec celui de ses sœurs ses
parents tranchent systématiquement en sa
faveur par exemple il se plaint que les
leçons de piano de s'assure Anna
l'empêche de se concentrer sur ses
livres d’école résultat le piano
disparaît et pourtant un piano à
l'époque c'est un attribut indispensable
pour une famille de la classe moyenne en
Europe centrale mais la future gloire de
Sigmund de justifier le sacrifice en
fait les parents ne font même pas
semblant de traiter les enfants de
manière égale ils accordent à Sigmund et
à lui seul un bureau privé une pièce
longue et étroite avec une fenêtre
donnant sur la rue bref il croit à fond
en son potentiel donc ils veulent le
mettre dans les meilleures conditions
afin qu'ils réalisent ce potentiel ce
que montre cette anecdote c'est que l'on
trouve dans le destin de Freud
l'ingrédient que l'on trouve dans l'IMM
la majorité des individus qui
accomplissent de grandes choses une
stimulation ou un conditionnement si on
veut initial et pour le coup la
psychanalyse dit des choses
convaincantes à ce propos effectivement
il semble que les aptitudes de l'adulte
soient souvent forgés dans l'enfance et
donc dans le milieu familial l'enfance
peut être un poids ou bien comme celle
de Freud un tremplin je me souviens
avoir lu dans un roman français je n'ai
pas retrouvé la citation que croire en
soi ne suffit pas pour accomplir de
grandes choses qu'il faut encore que
d'autres personnes croient en nous et
que leur foi alimentent notre motivation
je trouve que l'enfance de Freud
illustre bien cette idée
enfant Freud a souvent entendu une
légende à propos de sa naissance alors
que sa mère était heureuse d'avoir
accouché de son premier né une vieille
paysanne lui aurait prophétisé qu'elle
venait de donner au monde un grand homme
les parents de freux de son persuadés
qu'il a un grand destin et il a beau
galéré à l'âge adulte ils y croient
encore par exemple pour ses 35 ans son
père lui a offert une Bible dans
laquelle il a écrit en hébreu que
l'Esprit de Dieu la guidé vers le savoir
depuis l'âge de 7 ans non seulement il
est l'enfant préféré mais sa famille
nourrit en lui une énorme ambition
séparant lui répète qu'il est
exceptionnellement intelligent et ses
résultats scolaires confirment leurs
attentes extravagantes il est un élève
brillant toujours premier de sa classe
et un modèle pour les autres il passe
tout son temps dans le bureau privé que
lui réserve ses parents et travaille
tout le temps même quand des amis
viennent le voir il prend ses repas
seuls pour ne pas arrêter de travailler
bref Freud est un incroyable bûcheur et
son Excellence scolaire le confirme dans
la conviction qu'il est promis à un
grand avenir son ambition ne le quittera
jamais même quand il cherchera sa voix
même qui n'arrivera pas à percer sa
puissance de travail ne le quittera pas
non plus une fois qu'il aura son cabinet
il organisera sa vie et celle de sa
famille de manière très routinière afin
de pouvoir multiplier les consultations
tout en gardant assez de temps pour lire
et écrire généralement en soirée après
le dîner extérieurement Freud est un
conservateur mais les apparences sont
trompeuses il a beau vivre comme un
bourgeois se ambition ne s'accommode pas
de la morale bourgeoise il a beau
vouloir passer pour un scientifique son
ambition ne s'accommode ni de la
prudence ni de la rigueur austère de la
science voici comment il se décrit à un
ami en 1900 je ne suis pas du tout un
homme de science pas un observateur pas
un expérimentateur pas un penseur je ne
suis rien d'autre qu'un conquistador par
tempérament un aventurier si on veut
traduire ce terme avec toute la
curiosité l'audace et la ténacité d'un
tel homme ce que montre cette anecdote
c'est que Freud n'a pas eu une grande
influence grâce à sa découverte des lois
de l'esprit humain Freud voulait devenir
un grand homme dès le départ la question
que je me pose c'est est-ce que son
ambition démesurée ne l'a pas entraîné à
privilégier systématiquement
l'originalité à la vérité
le bureau privé ou le petit Sigmund
Freud passe tout son temps et bourré de
livres l’enfant passe la plupart de son
temps dans les livres à l'adolescence ça
continue il lit énormément
principalement de la littérature
classique et de la philosophie comme ses
parents croient en son destin il met
volontiers la main au portefeuille mais
une fois que Freud est un jeune adulte
indépendant ça devient compliqué pour
lui de financer sa boulimie de lecture
et oui à l'époque c'est pas 99 centimes
sur Amazon dans sa vingtaine Freud a
beau être un médecin débutant avec de
maigres ressources qui fait attention au
moindre euro il continue d'acheter
beaucoup de livres il ne peut pas
s'empêcher je suis un peu comme lui
seulement à plusieurs reprises ces
dépenses de livres le mettre sur le fil
du rasoir financièrement parlant par
exemple en 1900 à la mort de Nietzsche
il dépense beaucoup d'argent pour
acheter l'intégrale du philosophe
allemand et tous ces achats ne servent
pas à faire beau dans la bibliothèque
Freud continue de lire comme un affamé
il passe des heures dans les bouquins
chaque jour souvent jusque tard dans la
nuit je ne sais pas s'il a lu le conseil
de schopenhawer dans pas rerga et paraly
pomena mais Freud elle lit uniquement
classique les grandes oeuvres de la
Grèce antique Rabelais Shakespeare
Molière Goethe résultat des courses et
bien Freud et hyper cultivé dans sa
vingtaine il lit énormément de
philosophie d'ailleurs en troisième
année de fac de médecine il hésite à se
lancer dans un doctorat de philosophie
mais finalement il renonce ça ne
l'empêche pas d'être un érudit passionné
par les idées et ce qui est encore plus
important c'est qu'il va cacher son
érudition et oui comme la psychologie
c'est émancipé de la philosophie au XIXe
siècle freux d'Apple que son érudition
philosophique nuise à la réputation de
ces théories psychologiques que les
professionnels refusent de lui
considérer comme des théories
scientifiques s'il perçoit va
l’influence de théorie philosophique
quand on lui demande d'où viennent ces
théories il admet avoir lu des travaux
de psychologue de médecins bref
d'auteurs qui ont un crédit scientifique
et il admet sans problème que ces
travaux ont pu l'influencer mais il
n'évoque pas l'influence des philosophes
par exemple il raconte qu'il se saigne
pour acheter l'intégrale de Nietzsche
mais il ajoute qu'il n'ouvre même pas
les bouquins ça j'ai du mal à le croire
freudenit toujours
pas l'origine philosophique de ces
concepts par exemple shopenhaware initch
avait insisté sur le fait qu'il ne faut
pas sous-estimer les forces
inconscientes de l'esprit mais Freud
n'évoque pas ses penseurs quand il parle
de l'inconscient qui est en réalité une
idée très ancienne déjà présente chez
Platon par exemple que révèle cette
anecdote elle révèle que Freud n'est pas
un simple médecin un pur scientifique
bien au contraire il a beau avoir
renoncé à étudier la philo à
l'université il a une culture littéraire
et philosophique digne d'un grand
penseur mais voilà il ne veut surtout
pas que la psychanalyse passe pour une
théorie philosophique
adolescent à l'heure de choisir sa voie
professionnelle freudhésite il est tenté
d'imiter son meilleur ami de l'époque
qui choisit le droit avec l'intention de
faire de la politique mais Freud décide
de s'inscrire en médecine qu'est-ce qui
le fait changer d'avis son admiration
pour Darwin l'origine des espèces le
chef-d'oeuvre de Darwin qui a changé la
vision du monde des Occidentaux et
sortie 3 ans après la naissance de Freud
et depuis le naturaliste anglais est
devenu une star scientifique il est un
idéal un modèle pour beaucoup de jeunes
de l'adolescence au tout début de la fac
de médecine si on demande affreuse quel
est son rêve il répond un navire sur
l'océan avec tous les instruments dont
le chercheur a besoin il fait référence
aux mythique voyage de Darwin sur le
beagle qui a accouché de la théorie de
l'évolution cette anecdote montre que
Freud n'est pas un pur littéraire un
érudit qui aurait fait médecine par
dépit son énorme ambition a donc deux
faces littéraires et scientifiques
d'ailleurs sa théorie de l'esprit sera
empirique et il voudra même lui donner
des fondements physiologiques notamment
il travaillera beaucoup sur le système
nerveux au début de sa carrière la
psychanalyse sera finalement une
doctrine plutôt abstraite à la
scientificité douteuse mais Darwin
restera un modèle pour Freud il se
comparera à lui en disant que le
développement de la science a infligé
trois blessures narcissiques à
l'humanité Copernic a établi que la
terre n'est pas au centre de l'univers
Darwin que l'homme est un animal comme
les autres et enfin affreux de que
l'homme n'est pas maître de son propre
esprit c'est vrai que les idées de Freud
comme celles de Darwin ont rapidement
pénétré la culture occidentale jusqu'à
devenir des piliers de la mentalité de
l'homme moderne
comme vous savez les études de médecine
c'est pas l'histoire de deux trois ans
après ce que 30 ans Freud obtient une
bourse pour se rendre à Paris il va se
former auprès d'une neurologue
Jean-Martin Charcot à l'école de la
Salpêtrière ça vous dit quelque chose
Jean-Martin Charcot c'est le grand nom
de l'hypnose à la fin du 19e siècle
alors que l'hypnose n'était pas
considérée comme un sujet sérieux en
France Sharko l'a fait sortir de la
dissident en la présentant comme un
outil de vivis section psychologique il
prétendent notamment qu'elle permet de
comprendre l'hystérie l'hystérie c'est
un ensemble de troubles corporels par
exemple des crises nerveuses des
convulsions qui n'ont pas leur origine
dans le corps mais dans l'esprit à
l'époque Sharko est une véritable star
il est un personnage mondain de la haute
société il soigne les grands du monde et
il fait des cours remarquables son
service à la Salpêtrière fascine les
jeunes savants philosophes ça renommée
dépasse les frontières lorsqu'il
effectue un voyage en Russie par exemple
il est célébré comme un taux maturge
bien sûr Freud et sous le charme voici
ce qu'il écrit dans une lettre à sa
fiancée Charcot est un des plus grands
médecins sa raison confie nos génies il
faut dire que Sharko est très éloquent
qui beaucoup de charisme et ça joue
forcément dans son succès en tant
qu'hypnotiseur seulement Freud n'aura
pas autant de succès avec l'hypnose il
s'en sert quand il revient à Vienne et
ça ne plaît pas beaucoup à ses collègues
mais voilà c'est passion à lui ne se
laisse pas hypnotiser moi qui me suis
intéressé à l'hypnose et j'ai compris
que le succès de la méthode dépend à la
fois de la réciptivité de l'hypnotiser
et de la compétence de l'hypnotiseur et
apparemment Freud lui est loin du niveau
de Sharko en fait la psychanalyse naîtra
en tant que pratique thérapeutique de
l'abandon progressif de l'hypnose dans
les années 1890 Freud la remplace par la
méthode de l'association libre qui
consiste à laisser le patient exprimé
sans aucun contrôle les pensées qui lui
viennent les unes après les autres que
tirer de cette anecdote je pense que
l'importance de la mode de l'hypnose à
la fin du 19e siècle explique au moins
en partie pourquoi Freud insistera sur
l'importance de l'inconscient quand une
personne est sous hypnose c'est comme si
elle était quelqu'un d'autre et cette
seconde partie d'elle-même à la capacité
de créer des blocages chez la première
ou bien au contraire de libérer son
potentiel il y aurait donc en réalité
deux personnes chez l'être humain et le
psychanalyste comme l'hypnothérapeute
agit sur la partie inconsciente de
l'être humain pour le bénéfice de la
partie consciente
à 26 ans Freud de rencontres Marta
Bernays cette femme de 21 ans est
intelligente elle aime beaucoup les
livres comme lui et séduisante elle
plaît aux hommes deux mois seulement
après leur première rencontre il se
fiancent mais voilà il y a une ombre
tableau c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle la mère de Martha préférerait
que sa fille explore d'autres options
c'est quoi le problème freux des pauvres
certes Martin et par riche mais elle est
une fille de bonne famille Freud n'a ni
le prestige social ni les ans
financières après la mère de Martha
reconnaît que Freud et brillant mais
elle ne l'imagine pas percer rapidement
elle pense qu'il va galérer longtemps
avant de faire une grande découverte
scientifique d'atteindre la notoriété et
la prospérité et elle a raison Martha et
Sigmund vont devoir attendre quatre ans
avant de pouvoir se marier ils attendent
parce que Sigmund a posé une condition
il doit d'abord créer son cabinet de
consultation dont il tirera une source
de revenus fiable pour subvenir aux
besoins de sa famille avant que cette
condition soit réalisée c'est la galère
le jeune freux de se plaint de sa
pauvreté
il doit même emprunter de l'argent à des
collègues de travail cette période de
difficulté financière est d'autant plus
difficile à vivre pour lui qu'il a peur
que Martha le lâche à un moment pour un
meilleur parti à 30 ans il a enfin son
cabinet donc le mariage est possible
néanmoins l'argent ne sort pas de sa
tête pour autant il gagne plutôt bien sa
vie mais comme il a une profession
libérale ses revenus fluctu et lorsqu'il
est dans le creux de la vague l'angoisse
montant lui il a peur de retomber dans
la pauvreté de revivre ses qu'il a vécu
pendant les quatre années au cours
desquelles il a attendu de pouvoir se
marier il partage encore cet angoisse
dans des lettres alors qu'il a la
quarantaine cette anecdote montre que
Freud a un rapport particulier à
l'argent mais ce qu'elle montre
précisément ce n'est pas qu'il veut être
riche vivre dans le luxe des pensées des
sommes folles pour se faire plaisir ou
pour impressionner les gens non ce n'est
pas ça Freud veut gagner de l'argent
parce qu'il a été traumatisé par la
pauvreté en particulier la pauvreté a
failli lui coûter la femme de sa vie
certains ce scandalise aujourd'hui
qu'une séance avec freux ne pouvait
coûter grosso modo jusqu'à 500 euros de
c'est vrai qu'une fois est devenu
célèbre il n'hésitera pas à imposer des
tarifs très élevés aux riches patients
américains notamment attirés par sa
notoriété mais il faut remettre les
choses en perspective voilà un homme qui
a travaillé comme un chien depuis
l'enfance qui dans la quarantaine alors
qu'il est père de famille à encore peur
de ne pas pouvoir subvenir aux besoins
de ses enfants et de sa femme et qui n'a
pas emprunté des raccourcis pour devenir
riche et célèbre oui Freud voulait
gagner beaucoup d'argent et il en a
gagné beaucoup grâce à la psychanalyse
dans la seconde moitié de sa vie mais il
a énormément travaillé et il n'a volé
personne
comme je vous l'ai dit Charcot le
neurologue qui a formé Freud à l'hypnose
à Paris ce neurologue était un
personnage bond il organisait des
réceptions auxquelles Freud était invité
et la première fois Freud est
particulièrement stressée il est très
impressionné par la maison de Charcot
qui est plutôt un palais en fait Freud
n'est pas très à l'aise dans son costume
et en plus il a peur de se ridiculiser
en parlant français que fait-il pour se
donner du courage il se fait une ligne
de cocaïne il a découvert la poudre
blanche deux ans plus tôt lorsqu’il
apprend qu'un médecin de l'armée s'en
sert pour stimuler l'endurance des
soldats il décide de s'y intéresser il
pense que la cocaïne peut servir pour
réduire les troubles cardiaques pour
combattre la dépression pour des
anesthésies locales et pour réduire
l'addiction à la morphine le problème
avec cette dernière idée c'est que le
patient devient accro à la cocaïne donc
ça ne fait que remplacer une addiction
par une autre le rapport personnel de
Freud à la cocaïne ne se résume pas à
cette mauvaise idée un bon dealer c'est
qu'il ne doit pas toucher à sa propre
cam mais voilà Freud n'est pas un dealer
il se met à prendre de la cocaïne pour
ce stimuler pour contrôler sa tendance à
la dépression pour se sentir moins
stressé dans cette situation sociale
comme à la réception de Charcot et pour
se sentir plus confiant et oui la
cocaïne est décuple la confiance en soi
jusqu'à des niveaux problématiques Freud
aime tellement la cocaïne qu'il en
envoie par la poste à sa fiancée à mes
yeux cette anecdote explique
probablement l'étonnante confiance avec
laquelle Freud défendra ses idées
nouvelles parce qu'il y a une
disproportion entre d'une part la
fragilité des bases scientifiques et
intellectuelles des théories
psychanalytiques et d'autre part
l'assurance avec laquelle Freud défend
ses théories d'ailleurs nous savons
aujourd'hui qu'il a beaucoup généralisé
à partir de son propre cas et qu'il a
même pas mal menti aurait-il pris ses
risques s'il n'avait pas pris de cocaïne
d'ailleurs la fragilité des idées de
Freud apparaît aux personnes qui s'y
intéressent sérieusement même aux fans
de Freud même à son plus grand partisan
le numéro 2 de la psychanalyse si on
veut carl Gustav Youn travaille avec
Freud depuis les années 1900 entre les
deux hommes c'est une véritable histoire
d'amour intellectuel ils sont tous les
deux brillants et il s'éblouissent
réciproquement si bien que lorsqu'ils se
rendent visite ils peuvent parler 10
heures d'affilée young admirefood dont
il a lu les livres et freux de voix
young comme son plus brillant disciple
il le place d'ailleurs à la présidente
de l'Association internationale de
psychanalyses mais la relation se
détériore dans les années qui précèdent
la Première Guerre mondiale young de son
côté se rend compte que Freud cherche
plus l'autorité intellectuelle que la
vérité par exemple freux de refuse de
préciser certains concepts notamment la
libido il refuse de se laisser analyser
alors que c'est la règle pour tous les
psychanalystes enfin il donne aux yeux
de Young une importance excessive à la
sexualité Freud de son côté reproche à
Young de s'aventurer dans des domaines
qui sortent du champ d'application
naturel de la psychanalyse comme la
religion et puis la entre young
facilement jaloux et les autres
disciples et problématiques pour le
développement de la psychanalyse en 1914
young démissionne de la présidence de
l'Association internationale de
psychanalyse écrit sa propre école de
pensée psychologique pour Freud la
déception est profonde il avait placé
beaucoup d'espoir en young il le voyait
comme son potentiel successeur mais il
attendait de lui une indéfectible
loyauté à mes yeux cette anecdote révèle
la vraie nature du projet de Freud son
but est de promouvoir un mouvement dont
il est le maître Freud n'accepte pas
facilement voir pas du tout qu'on
remette en cause ses idées et puis
fondamentalement son autorité
intellectuelle comparé la psychanalyse
freudienne à une secte ou à une religion
si on veut c'est un peu exagérer mais il
y a une part de vrai comme la dénoncer
Carl Popper qui vivait à Vienne à
l'époque où s'y développer la
psychanalyse au point où les gens en
parlaient dans les cafés selon Carl
poper Freud a donné à ses idées l'irré
futabilité d'un dogme religieux puis il
a orchestré leur diffusion par ses
disciples un peu à la manière d'une
religion
je sais que certaines personnes ont une
capacité de travail hors norme par
exemple j'ai bien l'impression qu'il est
le musk travaille comme un cinglé mais
je sais aussi qu’une journée fait 24
heures pour tout le monde et que les
limites du corps et de l'esprit sont les
mêmes pour tous donc parfois quand je
découvre la routine de travail d'une
personne prétendument super productive
je n'y crois pas je sais qu'il y a un
pronom freud par exemple oui c'est un
travailleur acharné oui il est très bien
organisé et il a une puissance de
travail hors normes et oui il prend de
la coke mais quand même sa journée type
consiste principalement à voir entre 6
et 8 patients le matin et l'après-midi
et la raison d'une heure par passion
j'imagine et l'autre plage essentielle
de travail ce sont les heures de lecture
et d'écriture le soir et à côté de
toutes ces heures de travail au sens
strict il y a divers rendez vous le
courrier comme les mails de nos jours
les moments passés en famille les repas
etc bon ce qui me paraît suspect c'est
que Freud prétend effectuer chaque jour
environ 10 heures de travail nécessitant
un haut niveau de concentration les
séances avec les patients la lecture et
l'écriture or l'esprit humain n'en est
pas capable même le bon sens dit que
Freud est comme nous qui ne peut pas
rester concentré 10 heures par jour
alors comment fait-il et bien il n'est
pas concentré pendant les séances le
patient croit que Freud est concentré
mais il ne l'est pas il accorde à son
patient ce qu'il appelle une attention
flottante d'après lui ça permet aux
psychanalyse de laisser libre cours à
ses propres associations c'est à dire de
lever ses billets de confirmation
autrement dit c'est une méthode pour
interpréter objectivement la parole du
patient mais Freud à voir aussi que
l'attention flottante permet d'épargner
un effort d'attention qu'elle
s'apparente au demi-sommeil et conduit
parfois au véritables sommeil d'ailleurs
des patients auxquels il ne dit rien le
soupçonne de dormir Freud se justifiera
en disant qu'il économise son énergie
pour suivre beaucoup de patients chaque
jour ouais on a compris mais bon c'est
vrai que la plupart des séances se sont
inintéressantes pour le psychanalyste
d'ailleurs si vous interrogez un
psychologue il vous dira la même chose
80% de ces séances sont ennuyeux à
mourir pour lui le psychanalyste
écossais Edward Glover conseillera donc
aux analystes dans son manuel intitulé
La technique psychanalytique de se
forcer à prendre des notes afin de ne
pas s'endormir pendant la séance ce qui
n'est pas rare d'après la camp les
psychanalystes mettront cela en pratique
mais pas forcément dans le sens imaginé
par l'auteur du manuel certains se
serviront de la séance pour rédiger des
articles voir des livres entiers tout en
prétendant écouter le patient mais Freud
avait ouvert la voie il a avoué s'être
permis au début de sa carrière de
profiter de l’état d’hypnose de
certaines patientes pour écrire cette
anecdote montre que le fondateur de la
psychanalyse comme d'autres hommes très
connus entretient sa légende d'un homme
aux capacités hors normes
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu que vous avez découvert des
choses intéressantes et même inspirantes
sur Freud si c'est le cas donner un
pouce bleu à la vidéo et puis laissez un
commentaire pour améliorer les
référencement de la vidéo c'était pas
grand chose et puis ça m'aide vraiment
si ça vous intéresse sachez qu'il y a
également un cours de culture générale
sur la psychanalyse sur cette chaîne
Youtube ça vous permettra de creuser pas
mal de choses dont j'ai parlé dans cette
vidéo sur le mode de l'anecdote je suis
romain j'étais avec mon fidèle Aristote
et vous vous étiez sur 1000 idées de
culture générale rappelez-vous que vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée j'ai une question à vous poser
vous croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont il parle bien sûr
que non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand chose
et oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
Ronan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tranquille sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez